[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSHUA: I'm really excited
today to welcome Martin
Atkins to Talks at Google.
He's an entrepreneur--
[APPLAUSE]
Martin is an entrepreneur and
educator, a musician, producer,
DJ, and the list goes on.
With a 35-year career that
spans genres, borders,
and industries, you
could say that Martin
is the definition of
entrepreneurial activity
in cultural arts endeavors.
So to call out a few things
from his massive list
of accomplishments,
he was a member
of Public Image Ltd, founded
the industrial supergroup
Pigface, contributed
to Nine Inch Nails,
for which he won a Grammy,
as well as Ministry.
He's the owner of Invisible
Records, Mattress Factory
Recording Studios, and he's
the author of Book Smart--
or, excuse me, "Band
Smart," "Tour Smart,"
and I think I probably left a
few other titles out as well.
He is also the father of four.
Martin is also the
music business chair
at the SAE Institute Chicago.
I think a few of you
guys are here today.
And he's here to talk about the
creative industry with advice
for artists, musicians,
and entrepreneurs alike.
He has all kinds of tried,
tested, and remixed ideas
that all add up to
make a difference
in a creative and
arts-focused career.
He'll share his perspective
around longevity, efficiency,
and having a mindset to plant
the seeds of your own future.
So for Googlers in
the audience, be
sure to think of your
questions during the Q&A, which
we'll have up at the end.
So please join me in welcoming
to the Google stage, Martin
Atkins.
[APPLAUSE]
MARTIN ATKINS: Thanks
for that introduction.
That was kind of awesome.
You did miss out
one of my books,
"Welcome to the Music Business--
You're Fucked."
I think you did miss that one.
[LAUGHTER]
So yeah.
Started playing drums
when I was nine.
Joined my first
band when I was 11.
Started drinking Newcastle
brown ale and backing strippers
at the age of 12.
And it's just been--
speaking of longevity, it's just
been a long, slow, sad decline
from what, in retrospect, was
a career high at the age of 12.
This is just a little bit of me
from my time with Public Image
Ltd, between Johnny Rotten of
the Sex Pistols to the Suicide
Girls from "American Bandstand."
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Hello, what's
your name, please?
- Martin Atkins.
- Welcome.
- To MTV.
From Nine Inch Nails to Pigface.
[END PLAYBACK]
MARTIN ATKINS: Yeah.
I just like seeing that.
Me spitting and hitting this--
ruining microphones and stuff.
Two of my books.
My third book.
I always forget to
do this at the end.
So I want to do it now.
If you follow me on
Twitter, @marteeeen,
my hilarious '80s joke is four
E's, just like the old days.
Yeah, laughter over
here, from [INAUDIBLE]..
Students are sitting here
going, what's happening?
If you follow me on Twitter,
you get a free download
of my second book.
So what I'm going to--
this seems a little
bit grandiose.
Little stuff, big stuff, and
huge stuff, which is all I
could think of how to
describe this stuff.
First, before we
get into that, I
wanted to thank-- because
we're here in Chicago,
I wanted to thank Chance the
Rapper for donating $1 million
to Chicago public schools.
[APPLAUSE]
But is anybody else
thinking about what not--
you can do 1.5?
And you know-- but without
going off on too many tangents
before we get
started, do you have
any idea how many types of
Kit Kat there are in Japan?
It's absolutely bonkers.
Soy sauce, ginger ale--
I don't know what the
meeting was on that one--
red bean, pumpkin,
baked potato Kit Kat.
Yeah, and I'd love to say,
we're going to try them all.
Mark down on your cards which--
I don't have baked
potato Kit Kats.
I do have some Kit
Kats, if anybody wants,
if I can throw
out some Kit Kats.
Now, if some-- pay attention.
[LAUGHTER]
We're not having a Google law--
I was stabbed in the
eye with a Kit Kat!
These will come out--
I see you.
All right.
We'll get there.
Oh, there we go.
Well, and that's all
we have time for.
Does anybody want some Kit Kats
that doesn't have Kit Kats?
So should I just-- if
I pass this over there,
will it get past you lot?
AUDIENCE: No.
MARTIN ATKINS: You could take
a couple and pass it around.
That will work.
Honor system.
Also, while I'm not
on the subject yet,
I'm loving this book "Hit
Makers" by Derek Thompson.
I'm really, really loving it.
I think he's the senior
editor of "Vanity Fair"?
"The Atlantic."
It's just awesome.
And while I'm up here, I just
got Kevin Coval's 10th book,
which is slightly awesome too.
OK, enough of that.
Are there any rock
stars here today?
Let's try that again, shall we?
Hey, hey, Googlers!
Are there any rock
stars here today?
[CHEERING]
Absolutely.
That's more like it.
Hand in the air.
Hand on your crotch.
Doesn't have to be your crotch.
Anybody's.
But that's good news, because
Jimmy John's sandwich shop
is looking for some rock stars.
I don't mean to completely
deflate your ambitions,
but everything just keeps
changing all the time,
except this slide, which is
in every presentation I've
given in the last, I
don't know, 10 years.
Stuff just keeps changing.
Periscope-- well, there was
Meerkat before Periscope,
and no sooner had
I gone like that,
I was at South by
Southwest two years ago,
to kind of go, oh, Meerkat,
this is interesting.
Oh, by the time my
fingers hit the keys,
it didn't exist anymore.
And Periscope comes along.
And Instagress was awesome.
And now they changed the--
yeah.
I'm liking Ripl.
Ripl makes your still
images look like video.
It's kind of cool.
And this is just
a catastrophe now.
Turntable FM.
Does Vine still exist, even?
Wow.
See?
So good job I approached
it that way, because, yeah.
MySpace.
It's back!
No, it isn't.
It was-- even when it was back,
it was like, no, it isn't.
Hootsuite actually is awesome.
Landr is software that masters
your music in a heartbeat.
But as I said, it's just a mess.
Instagress, yeah.
Just loving it.
Everything keeps changing.
Dunkin' Donuts, making
chicken sandwiches.
Burger King, donuts.
The world's gone mad.
It's gone mad.
I'm like, what is how--
this is not right.
I drove past Kentucky Fried
Chicken down by the White Sox,
and the sign outside stays,
stop on in for a cake.
No!
I'm not gonna!
Vinyl is back from
near-extinction,
just after I threw
all my vinyl away.
I threw all the vinyl away.
Cassettes are back.
This was a Cassette
Store Day 2013.
And Punk is a beer.
Right?
Like, I was in a band with
Johnny Rotten for five years.
Right?
I came up through
punk in London.
And now it's a beer.
I want to go to the factory
and see the production line.
Kids with, like,
yellow mohawks--
At least we still have anarchy.
Don't we?
Here at Google, we still
have anarchy, don't we?
Sometimes I'll say
to my kids, hey kids,
you feel like a spot
of anarchy today?
They're like, yeah.
I've got four boys.
Yes, Dad.
I'm like yeah.
The revitalizing
shower gel from Axe.
I don't remember what
anarchy smelled like,
but it's not that.
I tell you what.
There is also Anarchy for Him.
Have you smelled it?
Yeah.
It's terrible.
It's really bad.
You just got off
a plane, Darren.
DARREN: Why is it just for me?
MARTIN ATKINS: Well,
you're English.
[LAUGHTER]
But ladies, yeah.
Anarchy for Her.
It all just blew back.
Now here's a tip
with Anarchy for Her.
You don't just spray it.
You spray and then--
you want to try some, Chelsea?
Eddie?
It's one-- pick one.
It's terrible.
It's really-- it's really bad.
Yeah.
It's just going to
be circulating now.
Yeah, there's the
Anarchy workout.
And this is [INAUDIBLE]
credit card.
There's nothing you
can do with that credit
card that makes it punk.
You could, like, buy a bag of
drugs with that credit card.
There's nothing you can
do with that card that
will make it punk.
[COUGHING]
[LAUGHTER]
OK, little stuff.
Let's look at some little stuff.
We'll move on to bigger stuff.
And we'll get to the huge stuff.
Well, maybe we'll spend so
much time on the little stuff--
who knows what's
going to happen.
Fear of selling.
Get over it.
You know, I pulled
up at a venue--
we were in Florida.
And I said to my friend
[? Curtis Mackey, ?] I
was doing a talk,
I'm like, should I
bring my merch in tonight?
Do you think it will sell?
And he said, really
smartly, well, you
won't sell any if you
leave it in the car.
And I'm like, oh my god,
I'm protecting myself
from putting my wares on
display, which sounds--
selling my stuff.
I'm frightened to sell my shit.
And we all do that.
You've got to get your stuff
out of the car and set it up.
And it's not about
the selling of it,
although it is if you need gas
money to get to the next gig.
It's about the transaction,
which is never about money.
It's a transaction
about relationship.
Rolling your T-shirts.
This is band-related stuff.
You roll your shirts.
Tip jar.
I keep forgetting this
tiny little thing too.
Have a tip jar.
I got an email from a band.
They said, that tip, the tip jar
tip, as it shall become known,
saved our band.
I'm like, what do you mean?
Like, well, it didn't.
But it kind of nearly did.
After our first show, we
had a bit of an argument,
and there was $15
in the tip jar.
And we took that and
we went to Denny's.
And we got, like, a band meal.
And it felt like they'd
been bought dinner
by some fictitious
record label or whatever.
Good luck getting $15
out of a record label.
But-- and over
dinner, they talked
about what was
right about the day
and what was wrong
about the day.
And it didn't save their
band, but it got them
to the next show.
And the $15 from the next
tip jar got them to the show
after that.
Just tiny stuff that
made a big difference.
You have to have
it say something
smart on your tip jar.
"Sexy people tip."
"Every time you tip,
God saves a kitten."
Of course that
needs to be changed.
"Every time you tip,
we'll guillotine a kitten"
at the back.
In my genre, that's how
you really make the--
and of course, you
need to have ambition.
Have more than one T-shirt.
Have a choice of shirts.
Your question cannot be,
would you like to buy a shirt?
Your question has to
be, blocking the exit,
which one of these shirts
are you going to buy now?
This one, or that one?
It's a very different question.
Give away your
songs all the time.
Give away everything
all the time.
And some musicians
still are like, yeah,
we'll give away
that demo or that
crappy live recording we did.
Or that mix that didn't work
out very well that was cheap.
Let's give that away.
You can't.
You have to give away your
best stuff all the time.
You have got this one chance
to start a relationship.
If you were a bakery, you've
got some smoked salmon things--
I've watching "The
Great British Baking
Show," so I'm about to go off
at some flaky vol-au-vent pastry
nightmare.
I'm honest-- yeah.
Great-- yeah.
You've got to watch it.
"Great British
Baking Show," very--
well, "Great British
Baking Show" and heroine,
really relaxing.
So you're at this
bakery, and you've
got this smoked
salmon vol-au-vent
thing that costs you a fortune.
It's complicated and
difficult to make.
You don't want to
give that away.
You've also got some stale
bagel chips that didn't turn out
very well, and somebody tripped,
dropped them on the floor,
and now you've got stale bagel
chips that people didn't really
like, and there's
probably some cat
hair mixed in with them too.
You can't give them away.
That's the end of
your relationship,
with your free stale
cat-hair-infested bagel chips.
You've got to give
away the smoked salmon
vol-au-vent thing.
And there's a relationship.
I'm hungry.
Anybody else hungry now?
It's time to remove
the protective cup.
So come on, everybody.
This is left over from
my sports lecture.
So '80s business, '90s
business, was this, wasn't it?
Everybody's
protecting their shit.
That can't be how
we act anymore.
You've got to put your
arms down to the side
and give people a hammer.
Here's the thing.
The bigger the hammer you give
to somebody, the less likely
they are to smash you
in the crotch with it.
Right?
If you do that, if you
put arms to the side,
you want to hammer my--
and you give me some GI
Joe toy miniature hammer,
I'll find a way--
I'll kill you with it.
If you give me a sledgehammer,
I'll be like, oh, yeah,
here we go.
Bring it on.
One, two-- I can't, mate.
Let's go have a beer.
The bigger the hammer you
give, the less likely people
are to smash you in
the crotch with it.
I don't just talk
about this stuff.
This is my version
of the hammer.
I did a thing on my
website Christmas Eve.
Hey, things are going
pretty good for me.
If they're not going very
well for you, pick a discount.
Emboldened by my
sledgehammer slide,
and I put those discounts up.
It felt like punk rock to me.
Right?
30%, 50%, 90%.
Do you know the discount
that I didn't imagine people
would use that they used a lot?
Zero!
I'm like, holy crap!
Why would somebody use 0% when
they've got a choice of 30%,
50%, 90%?
I don't know, but
lots of people did.
Because I gave a big
sledgehammer, 90%.
Next time I do this--
and I got busy,
but I'm going to do it again--
I think I'll do 100%.
Now, I'm not just going to do
100% and then go on holiday.
I'm going to do 100% and
sit by the laptop going, oh!
Oh!
Get ready to shut that down.
Oh, temporary-- oh,
the servers crashed.
Right, be smart about it.
But it's trust
that we're selling.
That's not right, is it?
It's trust that we're building.
It's trust that we're making.
It's trust that we choose
to create this obstacle
course for, in a way.
Yeah.
There's no real
reason for this slide.
There's a quote from Chuck
D. So I could see, I'm like,
yeah, so what Chuck D. says,
"What you know is what you save
and what you save
is what you make."
But really, it's
just me and Chuck D.
I was hanging out with
Chuck D. There you go.
There's no more of
that in this lecture.
It's just me and you
and Sir Richard Branson.
Anyway-- what an asshole.
Protect your assets.
You need assets.
Always have something
else to sell.
Right?
All this free stuff is
great, but if you only
have one shirt, one
song, one thing,
you're screwed when
you give it away.
You need 10 more things,
and other things besides.
So when you give
something away, you're
stimulating and
creating this other part
of this relationship.
Bigger stuff.
You want to spread your
message far and wide.
We start to think
geographically.
We start to look at a map.
Where are we going to go?
No.
Install a jacuzzi.
Go to culinary school.
Start brewing amazing beer.
Thanks, Lance, that's
one of my favorite beers
in the world, that is.
Buy some extra beds.
These are the reasons things
will be better two years
from now.
I met this woman
in Cleveland, and I
don't know if she was at a talk
somewhere, at one of my talks.
And she said, well, at least
I know, wherever my son goes,
he'll have people helping
him and protecting him.
I go, how do you know that?
And she shows me this book,
this tattered book, you know,
one of those lined books
with the pen stuffed in it.
And she did all of those things.
She went to culinary school.
They put a laundry
in the basement.
Four beds, screaming internet,
and invited every band coming
through town to stay with them.
And she made them breakfast.
She helped them
with the laundry.
Right, she did all
of that cool stuff,
and created connections for her
son, a safety net for her son.
I'm like, that's genius.
So we think of, how can
we be huge in Cleveland?
Stay where you are and invite
bands from Cleveland to come
stay with you, and then
go and stay with them.
Of course, some of
them will break up.
Some of them won't answer
the phone when you call.
That's just the
roll of the dice.
That's on them.
Don't just do more, be more!
Right?
I got a nice piece
on NPR about this.
I don't have time to
talk you through it.
My blackberry jam scam story.
But if you go to NPR,
"All Songs Considered,"
there's a few nice
stories, actually.
Me planting trees for
Bon Jovi's drummer.
High point for me.
What did you do
with your summer?
I was planting trees
for Bon Jovi's drummer.
You've got to stay on top
of the newest technology.
It's like ironic, right?
I'm standing here at Google.
You've got to stay on top of
all the newest shit, because--
[PHONE RINGING] Really?
Was there a sign?
Is that me?
Oh, it's me.
Sorry.
That is me.
Yeah?
Well, I'm doing a Google talk.
Yeah.
No, it's a hilarious--
yeah, it's a phone-- yeah.
But you do.
I'm joking about it, but
you know it's important.
Technology,
technology, technology.
AOL VOICE: You've got mail.
MARTIN ATKINS: What?
MARTIN ATKINS: Right.
You're laughing.
It's 9.0.
[LAUGHTER]
I've got AOL on my laptop.
One of my favorite
things to do when
I'm in the green room at
some conference, I'm like--
doot doot doot-- I make
sure my volume's on full,
make sure there's a
bunch of people sitting
in the green room talking
about their new startup,
and oh, we'll bootstrap
this and blah dee blah.
And I'll hit that.
And it's like,
honestly, I'm going
to have to start traveling
with an ambulance or something,
because the whiplash when people
hear that, it's just fantastic.
And I don't kind of get
up and go, ha, ha, ha!
I have to sit there and
pretend like I'm an idiot.
But they're the idiots.
Well, we got a little
bit off track there,
but let's get back to--
do something differ-net.
Defer-nit.
Do something different.
Do more of what works
and less of what doesn't.
That's the great thing about
all the apps and technology
these-- you can track
something immediately.
This is a great idea.
No, it isn't.
Change.
Iterate.
Do something else.
Efficiency.
I get pulled into
this all the time.
People want to do
things more efficiently.
There's no such
thing as efficiency.
We just did a Pigface
show last year,
and people bought
tickets from me.
And they got a pair of
T-shirts and some coupons
and some other stuff.
And so I'm sending out all
these packages to people.
I have a list of
all these addresses
of people who wanted to come
and see my band Pigface.
I'm like, well, I've
got to write a note,
and I have to put their name
on it, and I have to sign it,
which makes perfect sense if
you're talking to your grandma.
Right, there's 450
packages going out.
That's not nothing.
Then I put in a signed
CD, which is not nothing,
to unwrap a bunch of CDs, to
sign and then let them dry,
and then put them in.
Then I put handfuls of
candy in these envelopes,
because we're building or
cementing or reinvigorating
these relationships.
So efficiency is just not in it.
There needs to be a column
on the spreadsheet for vibe,
grooviness, and something
else I can't think of.
Right?
But that should be
on a spreadsheet.
We'll talk about longevity
in a bit, but yeah.
No reason.
I just like that slide.
Sometimes it feels
like he's pointing--
get the fuck over
whatever it is.
It's something.
Just get over it.
Technical ability.
This is worth mentioning.
I think many of us want to
be really good at one thing.
Doesn't matter.
I was hanging out
with Jon Langford
from The Mekons Tuesday night.
And he said, he
started The Mekons--
he played drums
in The Mekons not
because he was a good drummer.
He had a drum kit.
That was it.
And one of the guys, the
other guys in the band
said, you want to start a band?
Well, none of us can play.
Should we start a band?
And they did.
They're celebrating their
40th anniversary this year.
Here's a nine-year-old
prodigy guitarist
on the "Ellen DeGeneres
Show" about to meet Ozzy.
Here's a seven-year-old
drummer with 13 million hits.
Whatever it is you're good
at, type in to YouTube,
whatever you're good
at, "child prodigy."
Within three minutes,
you'll be down uBreakiFix
because you cried
into your laptop
and the salty tears
sparked your keyboard.
There might be one or two people
sitting there going, yeah,
this doesn't apply to me.
I'm a pilot.
Yeah, so is this
five-year-old kid from China.
Always say yes to everything.
Difficult for me.
I'm kind of shy.
And there's like-- so I'm
revealing this part of me.
You want to laugh?
Go ahead and laugh.
[LAUGHTER]
There's, like, a three-year
lag between one of my slides
and me actually doing
something about it.
I've just realized.
Right?
But I was at South
by Southwest EDU,
and I met the mayor
of Austin, who's
doing some amazing shit
right now for sure.
And it was this long day.
And just about to
get in the elevator,
and these Canadian educators
say, hey, let's go for sushi!
I'm like, I felt
myself going, eh, ah.
And I got like to, well, it's
been a long day, blah, blah,
blah.
You know.
And I'm like, remember your
slides from the last four
years, Martin!
And I'm like, yes!
Had the most
amazing time talking
about education in Canada.
It's very different
in Canada, obviously.
So I use this.
The guy who kind
of taught me that
was either Bjornson from
Enslaved, long story.
But it's kind of amazing.
Let's try, can we?
Let's have a pact between
ourselves here today
to be more awesome than
a pasta restaurant.
Can we do that?
Does everybody agree to be
more awesome than a pasta
restaurant?
Because yeah, a few
of you are thinking,
well, I thought
you said, past a--
I should have said pasta
restaurant, shouldn't I?
Pasta, restaurant.
But they had this thing,
I think a year ago,
where, hey, you want to come
in and eat some of our pasta?
We'll watch your
kids for two hours.
I'm like, wow!
So originally, I put
this slide in my talk
because it was like, wow.
And then I started to get upset.
Like, I'm pointing at a
pasta restaurant for us
to, like, aspire to?
You know?
And then I start to see bands
on Facebook, well, Ohio,
where were you Friday?
Where was everybody?
Where was our scene?
What's going on?
Just having a go at people
who didn't come to their show.
Nobody cares.
Nobody cares about
anything that's
important to you for a moment.
I'm in a band.
Yeah.
I'm a DJ.
Oh, I'm a terrible DJ.
You didn't mention that, Joshua.
I'm really bad.
I could destroy your wedding.
Not in a good way.
I could just completely
destroy your wedding.
But I thought, how many artists
would watch their fans' kids?
Right?
So let's aspire to do that.
Let's stop being shit.
Start being awesome.
Your brand is a
band and you want
to have your customers be fans.
So do your fans' laundry.
This is where I lose everybody.
Right?
If I'm doing a music, the
people are just like, oh, yeah.
Normally, I'll say, drugs!
We'll do something to
try and get people back.
But if you think
about it, I don't
know if you've got
Googlers here who are like,
hey, how's it going?
I don't know how
you guys get along.
But there's got to be some,
hey, record release party!
Oh, I'm busy.
I haven't told you
when it is yet.
No, but I'm going to be busy.
Nobody cares.
So why not have
your music release
party, you'll launch whatever
it is, at a laundromat?
Now the conversation
is different.
Hey, we're having
a release party.
Ooh.
And everybody gets two
loads of laundry done.
Oh, when is that?
Let me dial that in on my phone.
Boom!
Because nobody cares.
And sure, some people
will show up and just get
their laundry done.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
Screw them.
But you can manipulate
the situation.
You can slide the owner
of the laundromat,
$50 would probably do
it, to like, dial back
the temperature on the dryers.
So halfway in, you can
be like, hey, whoa.
Hey, sorry.
Terribly sorry.
No disrespect to you, Mike.
This is a fantastic laundromat.
There is a problem
with the dryers.
We're putting in a
more dryer sheets.
We're going to keep
the party going.
Somebody's brought
a case of beer.
Let's listen to the
album one more time.
And people are like, fuck.
You know, what are
people going to do?
You've got-- they're
held captive now
by their own wet laundry.
Right?
And sure, five listen--
yeah, two listens through
you could get away with,
with some Red Bull,
some other stuff.
But there will be people
who are going, screw those--
screw that.
But at least I got
clean underwear.
I'm thinking, nine
days later, when
they still got clean underwear,
they're like, screw those guys.
Ha, ha, ha.
I win!
But you know what?
Their songs are pretty good.
Kind of like them.
Let me dial that up again.
I wonder if they're
playing close by.
Right?
That's that trust thing again.
Nobody cares about
what's important to you.
Everyone's got dirty underwear.
You win.
This is where we
lose everybody else.
Get the fuck out of bed.
I'm lucky.
My kids are kind of grown now.
[INAUDIBLE] is eight, is
going to be nine soon.
But when he was three or four,
most mornings, ah, ah, ah!
4:00, 4:30, 5:00, I'm
getting kicked in the back.
I've got congealed puke
across the back of my neck,
similar to some
of the situations
I think you guys wake
up in most mornings.
But here's the deal.
I'm up at 5:00.
I'm five hours ahead
of my archrival,
ironically the lead singer
in a band called Arch Rivals.
Five hours.
Big deal.
But at the end of the
week, I'm 35 hours ahead.
That's 1,000-- I know you've
done the math in your head.
It's 1,820 hours a year!
76 days ahead!
That's the difference.
Just in case you're wondering,
the "get the fuck out of bed"
theme is also available as
fantastic performance art
pillowcase set.
And I'm not just a
crazy punk rocker.
You can't just have these
slides up at Google.
You have to have cats.
The cats swung it.
No, this get the fuck out
of-- oh, there's cats.
I think those are
[INAUDIBLE] cats.
"Dynasty" podcast cats.
The "Dynasty" podcats.
That's who that is.
Couple of quotes before I
get to the big, huge stuff.
This is Dale Carnegie.
My dad sent me this quote.
Thanks, Dad.
"You can make more
friends in two months
by being interested
in other people
than you can make
in two years trying
to get other people
interested in you."
That should have,
like, asterisk,
unless you do their laundry.
You know?
Love that quote.
Here's another good
one about community.
"A neighbor is
defined as one who
resides 40 houses to one's
right, 40 houses to one's left,
40 houses in front,
40 houses behind."
I think that's the Quran.
Always be nice to everyone.
Be nicest to the people with
the least reason for you
to be nice to them.
You can't be strategic
about being nice.
Just be nice.
The good thing is,
there are some people,
being nice to them, you'd
have to buy them a car.
And if someone's at
that point where you've
got to buy a car for them
to go, thanks for the car,
the car isn't going to
make a difference anyway.
The time to make a difference is
when it's a smile, a sandwich,
not being an asshole.
Right?
That's a huge thing to
do, to be nice to someone.
You don't know the context.
Maybe their partner
just left them.
Maybe they just got this
ridiculous electric bill,
or a speeding
fine, or something.
Just be nice.
See what I did here?
With the huge-- it's so big,
it's like a typography thing.
We don't have to
get into it now.
If you-- I'll be sticking
around afterwards.
How do we put 20,000
fans in a stadium?
I'm going to answer
that question,
and more on my
subscription site.
That's like a question, right?
How do we do that?
How do we get to there
on the Billboard chart?
Yeah, don't know.
I don't fucking know.
But I know something.
I know every single
person in this room
could make friends with two
people, today, of all days.
You want to?
And we're not going to do
some, like, turn to the person
to your left, punch
him in the face.
We're not going to do it.
But that's all this stuff is.
If you make two
friends today, or six,
I'm not going to do the math.
We'll keep it at twos, right?
Every day you make two friends.
Now it gets a little
bit plate-spinny.
You've got to stay in
touch with the friends you
made eight weeks ago, right?
You've got to keep
that plate spinning.
But that's all it is.
When you approach it as, how
do we put 20,000 people in--
you're screwed.
If you approach it as, I
could make two friends today.
And you get better at it.
You'll have days where
you make 20 friends, or 20
potential longer-term
friends, right?
And you'll have days where you
do some terrible stuff that
doesn't make any difference.
That's it.
There isn't any huge stuff.
There isn't huge stuff.
There's just small
stuff plus time.
That's all there is.
And so we've all
been, like, what
is that, we're like
Stockholm syndrome
prisoners of music business.
And the keyholders who want us
to believe, like, hoo hoo hoo!
One day, it's
behind this curtain.
Actually, there's a
door behind the curtain.
We could go through there.
There's another room
with more curtains.
We'll pull the curtains.
You get the key.
That gets the key to the
digital combination of the--
one day we'll take you there.
I said, now what do you know?
There's no fucking
secret to any of it.
It's just one day,
making two friends.
One day, making
two more friends.
You know, when I came up,
a lot of really good things
happened to me very quickly.
I was on the front
cover of "Melody Maker."
That was just weird as hell.
Used to walk past the newsagents
on my way to my government job
when I was 18 in London.
And I'd see "Melody
Maker," "NME," "Sounds,"
all those magazines.
"Smash Hits," probably.
And like, fantasize, like,
one day that could be me.
At the age of 18, I'm
on the front cover.
We're doing live television.
We came over here.
We did "American Bandstand."
Went to Japan and
did all this stuff.
But I had this smash and
grab mentality of, like,
that I would have less time
than a superstar soccer player.
Right?
Like, we got two years!
Grab that case of beer!
We're-- not realizing, you
know, I met Joe Shanahan from
the Metro in 1981.
I still see him with his
kids at Dave & Buster's.
Right?
You just don't think like that.
You're just like, get the--
grab the bottle of whiskey.
There's just relationships,
people, trust, and community.
And once you start looking
at things like that,
the efficiency thing
is just a no-brainer.
It doesn't matter.
If I'm creating a relationship
that could go on for--
touch wood.
Oh, there's no-- of course
there's no wood in this--
relationships that could
go on for 30, 40, 50 years.
The front end takes
whatever it takes.
It's not one thing.
It's 300.
Or 420.
Got the students back.
Lost some students
with the laundry.
Oh, yeah.
This genius!
It's genius, what
he's saying now.
In big letters, 420.
420 big.
Oh, no, losing it.
What's going on?
420,000 is the number.
Anybody know what
that number is?
No.
OK.
It's how many cats you get
if you don't spay one cat.
[LAUGHTER]
Google it.
[APPLAUSE]
Right.
If you don't spay
a-- of course, it's
not from that one cat, which
I think you were thinking.
From all the cats that
come because of not spaying
that cat, there's
probably eight,
the first time it has a litter.
Bum, bum, bum.
So what we need to be is--
well, we can't--
we got to spay--
I don't want to say
we shouldn't-- right.
But one of my kids said to
me, this marketing thing, Dad.
It's like zombies.
It's like a zombie thing.
I'm like, where are you
going with this, son?
[INAUDIBLE] and like, well, it's
like, a zombie bites a person,
and then there's two.
And then those two
zombies bite two more,
but then there's four.
It's like grains of wheat
on the chessboard, right?
Eight, 16, 32.
So my last piece
of advice to you
is to be a not-spayed
zombie kitten.
[LAUGHTER]
That's the title
of my next book.
That's rar, rar!
Well, that's what we got to be.
Not-spayed zombie kittens,
biting people, having--
yeah.
And of course, we always
need to throw muffins.
That's my shit.
[APPLAUSE]
I don't have any control
over these bags of muffins.
Is anybody desperate
for a muffin?
It's not code.
It's just-- once again, please,
eyes forward, eyes forward.
Well, see?
I just got Dan in the ear.
One of my favorite moments
at South by Southwest,
I picked up a box, right?
And I thought I couldn't
get the little bags
all the way to the back.
I thought, well, I'll
just kick this, right?
There was somebody sitting--
it hit-- I've never-- you've
never heard such a bang.
It just hit this
guy in the face.
And we're still friends to
this day, which I just--
I don't know why I'm
saying-- anybody want to go
for the whole--
it's easy sitting there with
your bags of muffins going,
yeah, I thought, overall,
the talk was pretty good.
He made some good points
and blah, blah, blah.
People don't realize
the preparation that
goes into something like this.
Like, I'm sitting
up all night opening
these bags, masturbating
into these bags,
and then heat sealing.
This is like, six or
seven hours, right there.
[LAUGHTER]
That's my-- that's me.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]